hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast holiday message
I'm your host Sean Carroll and as you
might gather from the title holiday
message this is not gonna be a regular
episode of the podcast I was thinking of
just skipping the two weeks the holiday
period for Christmas and New Year's but
I realized I didn't really have an
effective way to communicate that fact
to the outside world not everyone
subscribes to the Twitter feed
there is a mailing list that you can
sign up for on the podcast website
preposterous universe comm slash podcast
there you go
and you can either sign up for being
notified whenever a new episode comes
out but also you can sign up for
announcements like I'm not going to be
doing the next two weeks but that's a
tiny fraction of listeners who actually
do that so I hit upon the idea just
recording a short little message that
would review a little bit about the year
in the podcast mostly since its brand
new and everything is new and shiny and
new to me anyway so this is going to be
an extremely self-indulgent navel-gazing
solo mini episode it might not be your
cup of tea that's perfectly okay stop
listening now that's fine this is just a
thank you for all the people who have
been listening supporting and just
enjoying the podcast so let's go
[Music]
so some of you may know I have been on
many podcasts before I've been a guest
of them before and it's always been a
question you know should you start your
own podcast I was a pretty early adopter
into the blogging game and relatively
early in social media also but
podcasting always just seemed like
another level of commitment you need
equipment he needed maybe another person
I wasn't sure what it would be you know
basically the the problem was you could
either do it completely solo right you
could do podcast with nothing but me
talking every single episode or you
could do a team podcast or you had other
people or you could just do kind of an
interview style one-on-one thing and I
had strong objections to all these
different possible formats so I wasn't
really very tempted by the possibility
of doing a podcast myself in terms of
just being solo every single time I
didn't think I had that much to say and
if I did I could just blog it in terms
of assembling a team or something like
that that seems like way too much work
and the interview stuff also seemed like
work with the extra downside that I had
done a bunch of interviews for my book
the particle at the end of the universe
when I wrote about the Higgs boson and
its discovery at the Large Hadron
Collider and the act of being a
journalist I discovered and while doing
that book is just not my bag that's just
not what I'm good at
you know getting other people to tell
funny stories and things like that
however a couple of things happened well
one thing happened really a friend of
mine you sort of prodded me that he I
really should think about doing a
podcast myself and what I realized is
that subsequently I had written another
book at the big picture and I had also
interviewed people but it was in a
different sense that I was interviewing
them when I was interviewing people for
particle the end of the universe I
really was acting like a reporter right
not like a scientist but when I was
interviewing people for the big picture
it wasn't that I wanted their personal
anecdotes or their stories of
discovering things it's that I wanted to
know what they were thinking right I
wanted to discover what their ideas were
and how I could incorporate that into my
book and that process I really did enjoy
so once that book was over
have lost the license to go around and
do that you know I got two I had
previously been able to email people and
say hey would you talk to me for my book
and and very often they would say yes
so someone pointed out that doing a
podcast would give me that license back
I would be able to talk to people
physicists of course in my own field but
all sorts of people all over the place I
could talk to and that would be a way to
get conversations going about a wide
variety of different topics so I looked
into a little bit and I I figured I
would give it a shot we'll see how it
goes so far I think it's going pretty
well and I'm enjoying it anyway I've
managed to do one every week since I
started which is much more than I might
have expected ahead of time but to be
honest getting it going was way harder
than I thought
as you know the first episodes came out
in July but I was working for a couple
months before then do you know you have
to buy equipment it really does take you
open is not like blogging somebody need
to sit down your computer you need
microphones Union recorders and wires
and things like that plus you need to
upgrade your website and you need to
host the podcast somewhere and there's a
million different things you need to do
and that was I did a lot of research on
the right way to do it and that was
overall more work than I expected I'll
be very honest about that
it's just me doing the podcast right
like I don't have a studio I don't have
a producer I don't have a web guru or
anything like that so the guiding
philosophy in every aspect of the
podcast is how can I get it done with
decent quality and minimal effort
minimal work minimal hours per week that
I'm sorry that that's the guiding
philosophy but it's not my day job it's
a little hobby on weekends mostly so I
have to keep it you know compact and
manageable but I did so that led me to
put a good deal of work into the
equipment aspect of things because I
figured if I'm not gonna have a
professional studio or producer or sound
editor or anything like that the best
way that I can get decent sound quality
on
Podcast without putting in a lot of
effort is to get decent equipment so
fortunately there's a place right near
where I live called vintage King which
is a quite well-known place selling
audio and recording equipment mostly to
you know professional musicians and
things like that that's the benefit of
living in Los Angeles and Robert at
vintage Kings shout out to him was
wonderful helping me pick out the right
microphones and recorders and things
like that so for those of you who are
fascinated for most of the podcasting I
use electro-voice
microphones I keep wanting to call them
electro volt because or electron volt
because I'm a physicist but they're
electro-voice are e320 microphones which
are very very nice maybe a little bit
bigger and bulkier than I would like for
portability purposes but they work great
once they're set up and I record them
into a sound design mix pre 3 recorder
mixer it's probably overkill for my
purposes to be perfectly honest it's
it's a quite a high quality little
recorder but maybe as I go more more and
learn more what it can do then I'll use
the actual mixing and you know on the
road adaptability of the Machine a
little bit more but overall I think the
sound quality is pretty good I know that
it's not always as good as I want it to
be part of that is exactly because the
podcast themselves the interviews happen
in a wide variety of different
circumstances you know right now I'm
sitting in my office alone and I can
make things pretty quiet in pretty good
shape but very often these podcasts are
done elsewhere they're done on the road
so and I've tried different you know
recording techniques whether to use
headsets and things like that but you
know sometimes I'm in someone's house
and there's just very echoey right like
they have no carpets in their room or
whatever other times I'm recording
remotely so I have to rely on someone
else to have their microphones etc and
you know I also have to record you know
rely on the ability of them to record
the sounds I do use this thing called
Zen caster which is a online service
that I get recorded and they get
recorded separately and then their file
is sent to me basically downloaded
so it's not like Skype where I am
recording their voice over the Internet
both I and the guest are recording
separately and then I can mix them
together I think it's working pretty
well somehow you know for some guests
despite the fact that I know what
microphones they're using and they
should be good the sound quality isn't
always there so I'm still exploring how
to get that as good as possible but
that's all part of learning on the job
so I think that the good news is that
once I got started once I got the
equipment and once I got the website
going etc it's been easier than I
thought has been less work than I
thought to actually record the episodes
and get them on the internet that was I
thought that the getting the podcast
started would be easier than it was but
I thought also thought that keeping it
going would be harder than was and
frankly that's a better way for that to
have worked out you know honestly I
spend a couple a few hours a week doing
the podcast overall including inviting
people interviewing them and turning
those audio files into an episode like I
don't it's pretty obvious to you I'm
sure I'm not doing a lot of
post-production on the audio files
there's a lot of special effects and
editing and clipping or anything like
that but you know I do put up the show
notes on the web page and you know send
out the Twitter and the email list etc
but all told for a typical episode it's
like three or four hours of work so
that's quite sustainable I think that is
you know hobby level stuff if it becomes
even you know five or certainly ten
hours of work then that's just very hard
to fit into my life because it's not my
day job and it's never gonna be my day
job so so far so good and and also out
the other great news is that finding
guests has not been hard one thing is
that when you start a podcast suddenly
people want to be on your podcast who
you never met before you get emails out
of the blue and I'm actually I'm
perfectly happy with people emailing me
saying I want to be on your podcast
because I'm perfectly happy saying no if
I'm not interested so hopefully they're
not insulted by that I have certainly
been on a lot of podcasts and I've been
invited and I often say no because I get
more invitations than I can quite take
care of but sometimes the people who
email me I look
what they're doing and go wow that's
really kind of cool so it's it's a good
thing so I'm very happy to do that and
also you know with some exceptions I
have emailed people or contacted them
people I know and people out of the blue
inviting them to be on the podcast and
some of them have said no and again I
have zero problem with that I know that
other people are very busy you know
we're aiming high in terms of getting
guests on the podcast so when someone
says yeah I'm too busy to do that no
problem whatsoever from my and I more
than enough great people coming on so
that's a lot of fun if anything I did
that one solo episode talking about why
is there something rather than nothing
and people keep saying when you gonna do
another one honestly I have too many
good guests coming up I haven't had room
in the schedule to fit a solo episode
but I will I do have that in mind that's
going to happen down the road as
everyone knows I've set up a patreon
account for supporters to kick in that's
been a wonderful thing and I always say
I'm gonna keep saying it enormous
appreciation for everyone who donates on
on patreon it's certainly you know that
it paid an immediate benefit because by
actually making money off the podcast
rather than hemorrhaging money I was
able to upgrade by adding transcripts of
all the episodes so if you go to the
actual web page for bosphorus universe
universe comm slash podcast every entry
for an episode has a complete transcript
so that cost money but I think it's well
worth the value added because for one
thing you can search right you can go to
the podcast web page search for quantum
mechanics or bayes's theorem and see
where it shows up in the in the text of
all the transcripts so hopefully that
would be a very useful thing going
forward so enormous thanks to all the
patreon people I've also been doing
monthly ask me anything episodes for the
patreon supporters and that's been a lot
of fun that's been a little bit more
work maybe than I thought because I have
like read through all the questions but
it's so much fun to do it because there
you know there's a wide variety of
questions not all the questions are
really great but some of them are really
really good and many of them are
thought-provoking and make me think
about things that I
that I hadn't thought about you know I'm
still thinking about the question about
whether I prefer the Beatles to the
stones and I mean the answer is obvious
I prefer the Beatles but then you know
as a scientist as a scholarly person you
want to give the right answer for that
and you know now I've been thinking for
last couple weeks about why is it really
that the Beatles are so much better than
the stones well I should have said only
ask me anything but didn't is I even
think that the who are better than the
stones so I'm not really the guy to ask
if you want a support or someone to
explain why the Rolling Stones are that
great I have respect for their work over
the years but they're just not my
personal cup of tea of course other
people you know if you listen to the
podcast and don't support honestly
that's also fine I get it I listen to
some podcasts and a couple of them I
support and the ones that I will only
listen to you know a single episode or
so I don't but I get it
you know if you just not in a financial
position or whatever or just don't think
that that's the way that economics
should work no problem whatsoever I
appreciate those who do support I don't
have any objections to those who don't
to those there are some people who don't
like patreon as a platform if you want
somehow to send me money for whatever
reason and don't like patreon there is a
PayPal link on the webpage you can
ascend payments you know for the year
you don't need if you don't like
recurring payments for example you can
just say well there's gonna be 50
podcast this year I want to pay a dollar
per podcast well to send 50 bucks that's
perfectly okay the bad news about that
is that patreon as far as I can tell
maybe I'm missing something but I like I
said I did do a bunch of research here
patreon is is the only service which
will let me do the two things that I
really want number one charge people per
episode rather than per month because
I'm not gonna guarantee that there will
even be podcast episodes every week much
less every month right
you know that's it's it's not the
highest priority in my life so it may
very well be that nothing happens at
some point and so I want to charge
people for the content that they are
actually receiving not just for you know
every month or week or something like
that and number two it's a very easy
setup to give the reward
like the ask me anything episodes it's
very easy to give people access if
they're if they're pledging on patreon
and it's hard to do that through PayPal
or anything else now maybe that will
change maybe the landscape is changing
there's a rumor that the people at
Kickstarter are starting their own
service that will compete with patreon
so who knows you know I'm not wedded to
it but so far so good with that
good so that's the sort of stylistic and
procedural aspects of doing the podcast
in terms of the intellectual motivation
that I mentioned already you know that I
wanted to talk to people both inside and
outside my own subject area it's always
a little bit different
talking with physicists than talking
with non physicists because you know
both because I know more about what they
do so like I have to fake it right I
have to say like so tell me what is the
Big Bang when I'd know perfectly well
what the Big Bang is but they get that
that you know that that's ok it helps
the audience who might not be made of
physicists but also there's certainly
this temptation when you're just talking
to another physicist and you both know
what you understand sometimes you skip
some of the background information so
what I'm talking about you know
cryptocurrency or gene-editing when I
know nothing then I'm just being honest
asking the questions I want to the
answers to and so with physicists it's
actually a little bit trickier if
anything and I know and this is a touchy
subject I know because there's certainly
a fraction of the listeners out there
who have made their feelings very clear
that they want nothing but physics that
they get annoyed when it's anything
other than physics and you know for what
it's worth I get annoyed back at them
had you guys I love all the supporters
but it's my podcast and I want to talk
about whatever I want to talk about and
you know if you don't want to support it
don't listen that's also completely fine
but I would not do nothing but physics
podcast I have no interest in doing that
I love it when I get suggestions for new
things to do that I like because you
know again with I take them or not I
will track them down that will you know
look into it and see if there's a person
or a topic that I wouldn't otherwise
have covered that's very very helpful
but anywhere
on the Internet if you like take your
time to go to someone who is creating
stuff and say don't create that create
this other thing that I care about it
just doesn't seem like Apple itest way
to be a person on the Internet to me my
personal interest is in all sorts of
intellectual questions and endeavors and
physics for me is the best of all
different areas we can talk about
because it you know it digs deeply and
it has precise answers and I like the
equations and the diagrams and so forth
but it's a small part of the wider
landscape of questions we can ask and if
anything I think that I would love to
see lower barriers between science and
other areas of intellectual endeavor
whether it's in universities or in the
media or in pop culture or whatever I
think that science should be part of our
conversational landscape we shouldn't
silo science over here and then
everything else over there it's the same
kind of thing that we're doing whether
it's science or economics or philosophy
or you know politics or art or design as
we talked about you know we're trying to
get ideas that help us comprehend this
messy world that we live in so that's
not gonna go away sorry for those of you
who are disappointed by that but they're
still gonna be you know more than enough
physics on the podcast going forward so
I hope I should be very clear most
people seem to be totally on board with
this most people seem to enjoy the
different kinds of episodes very much so
that's always been gratifying to hear
again the suggestions for new things to
do are generally welcome except if they
cause more work for me that's I'm just
trying to be brutally honest here I know
a lot of people would love to have you
know video or have the conversations go
for three hours or you know have have
more of the conversations in a studio
where the sound could be better
controlled and all these would be great
but all these would be much more work
for me you know I do do preparation for
the different guests especially the ones
who are not physicists and I didn't
count that when I said it takes three
hours per week and do an episode I did
not count the time I spend you know
reading the book of the person or
reading articles that they were
but I don't count that because that's
kind of fun stuff I would do anyway
that's not just podcast preparation
that's just me reading interesting
things so it doesn't really count but
something like video or you know more
explicit editing and things like that
that that's just more work you know and
and if if you're Joe Rogan when you make
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
episode for podcast by all means that's
a sensible thing to do for me who is you
know doing it in my office on my spare
time for the foreseeable future
mindscape is just gonna be audio I
shouldn't be making any promises about
the far future because who knows what
will happen I do appreciate that video
would be better in some sense it's great
to have you know the visual impact of
seeing someone talk and seeing two
people interact with each other I
totally get that but the value added
seems to me to not outweigh the effort
required so that's just a sort of
cold-hearted calculation on my part
which as I said you know could possibly
change far down the line but it's
unlikely to change in the immediate
future so yeah so I think it's been a
good year or half a year you know we
launched in July Carroll Tavis the
social psychologist was my first guest
and I think in retrospect you know that
was one of the good choices I made
having Carol is being the first guest
because we talked about cognitive
dissonance and biases and how human
beings justify their bad decisions and
are not perfectly rational and you know
one of the aspirations of the podcast is
to be a little bit more rational to be
better thinkers about things and so
you're mapping out some of the dangerous
territory there was a very good way to
start one of the things that I read more
than once about starting your own
podcast is that you should start with
the bank so that you should have like
multiple episodes in the first week just
so people have a lot of content to look
into and I did that Carlo Rovelli Alice
dragger tawny pin I released four
episodes that first week and I feel in
retrospect maybe like I'm cheating a
little bit especially Alice dragger and
tawny pin both of whom gave wonderful
interviews especially considering that I
was you know brand-new edit my
but they they have less listens to those
episodes than a the other ones because
there's a lot of content coming out at
the same time so if you're a relatively
new listener I encourage you to go back
into the archives and listen to those
because they're really a lot of fun and
they're different in interesting ways
because those are two very smart
different people that are good to listen
to I've enjoyed a lot of the episodes I
mean I almost don't want to pick out
episodes and name-check people
specifically because then some people
won't be named jacked and I feel bad but
I've enjoyed them all they've all been
great I don't think there's been any one
real dud that I haven't enjoyed I'm not
sure what I would do if I interviewed
someone it was just a disaster I didn't
even want to put it up on the air but
but truth I have not had the had that
happen yet so we'll see about what goes
on you know some of the more out there
episodes are the ones I've enjoyed the
most wynton marsalis which is it's a
special opportunity that I was lucky
enough to take advantage of scott
derrickson the the movie director livery
the poker player Joe walleston and I had
a wonderful conversation about
population ecology and conservation
Nahan Narula
talked about the blockchain and
cryptocurrency and these are all kind of
weigh out things I don't get to
experience in my everyday life so it's
been these episodes that for me have
said yes this is a smart thing that
you're doing with this podcast you get
to talk about these ideas that otherwise
you know will just go by the wayside so
it I wish everyone could have a podcast
so they could talk to these people and
if not they should listen to this one
in terms of listening to this one you
know people want to know like how do you
get your podcast listened to how do you
build an audience and so I only have one
good piece of advice there which is to
be on Joe Rogan's podcast I was on Joe's
podcast soon after I started my own and
there's a huge leap tenfold increase in
the number of people listening to
mindscape after that happened so thank
you Joe Rogan and thank you to all the
listeners who came from there since then
to be very honest the audience is more
or less stayed stable it's stated about
the same level is up in much growth or
shrinkage even from episode to episode
it's been more or less predictable and
constant and
I would love to grow it you know I'd
love to have even more people listening
but again not the day job I you know I
don't spend money promoting it I don't
even put much thought into getting it
out there so if anyone has any ways of
getting even more people to listen that
would be great it's already a pretty
crowded podcast market out there so I
totally get that as a relative newcomer
it's hard to get people who have their
favorite podcasts already to start
listening to something new so I get that
too but yeah I figure I'm not gonna
spend a lot of effort in promoting it
what I will do is just try to make good
content plug away hopefully the word
keeps getting out there you know there's
always the question of taking ads on the
podcast which I'm not doing yet I
maintain that maybe someday that could
happen I'm certainly not making as much
revenue from the patreon as I would from
ads and I've had you know people email
me asking to put ads on but so far you
know the patreon revenue has been enough
that I prefer the cleanliness the
straightforwardness the simplicity of
just having the podcast be the podcast
you know that could if ads are in the
future then that's fine but right now I
kind of like it
just keeping it clean and pure and
simple that way coming up in 2019 like I
said I've already I have no problem
getting people to come on the podcast
which is really good news I have you
know interviews scheduled that will take
the content through the end of March
here we are in December of 2018 so and
plenty more great targets out there some
old people some young people some famous
people some unknown people physicists
lots of other areas I like this idea of
not letting anyone know who's gonna be
on the podcast until the episode
actually drops I have no idea whether
that is a clever marketing strategy or a
disaster did not research that one at
all I just kind of liked it that you had
no idea what's coming a little bit of a
surprise for everyone on Monday morning
so my my my goal over the course of this
upcoming year podcast wise is actually
to just get better at my own skill set
I mean I have enormous respect for
people who are good at what they do and
one of the things that people can do is
be podcast thousands so I you know I
have fun at doing it and I try very hard
to make sure the people who I talked to
her ones who I can get along with in
some sense have a productive and
friendly conversation with so but I'm
definitely learning and trying to get
better at it early on I think that I
actually tried to plan a little bit too
much you know had a roadmap for where
the episode would go and as time goes on
I'm planning less and less I'm preparing
just as much but in my mind I you know I
might have well the here's our three
things I want to talk about let's make
sure we get there and let's see where it
goes and you know usually there's no
trouble filling the time that has never
been trouble filling in time honestly we
could always keep talking for a long
time so so far so good I'm happy to take
you know suggestions about that does you
know being an interviewer being a good
host is certainly an area where I could
stand to improve and hope to grow and
I'm open to constructive criticism there
you know it's always an interesting
question about how you approach the
philosophy of being a host or being
interviewer on a podcast like are you
being confrontational are you you know
trying to be technical are you trying to
be open like my goal is to give the
guests a space in which they can make
their points the best way they possibly
can and I don't want to argue with
people even if I disagree with them what
I will do is suggest the objections I
have and I've done that and I try to do
that better and better I want the people
who are listening to know what those
objections might be but I'm not gonna
you know sit someone down and insist
that they bow down to my superior logic
if they've been nice enough to appear on
my podcast I will let the audience know
what my objections are and then you
folks can go look them up right if it's
interesting I I think of almost all
media you know short form media where
short is anything an hour or less or two
hours or less you know you're not gonna
learn a whole new subject and something
like that it's not like a semester long
of course so I think at best you can put
some new ideas into people's heads and
inspire them to follow up it's not you
know you're not gonna learn if I'm
talking to David Chalmers you're not
going to learn everything there is to
know about the philosophy of
consciousness it's just not gonna happen
but you might get a little map of the
territory and you might think oh that's
interesting I'm gonna go read it so
that's why I have these links in the
show notes for every episode you know
places to follow up and some you might
not be interested in following up but
they're there that that's more the goal
and so I think this is a good philosophy
of podcasting I think it's been pretty
good so far and I'm gonna try to get
even more people who I don't agree with
on the podcast coming up you know there
are people who I don't want on the
podcast again like I want Pleasant
productive conversations even with
people who I disagree with that's
basically the goal sometimes I will
agree with them sometimes I'll disagree
but it should be a productive
intellectual engagement one way or the
other I think that's it I think that's
it for my thoughts my navel-gazing
thoughts on the mindscape podcast there
are other things going on of course that
it did go on through the year I'm
writing a book as I keep mentioning I
hope people don't get too annoyed and me
mentioning my book all the time but that
is what I've been doing a lot of my own
brain power has been going to that in
recent months so I'm writing a book
about quantum mechanics it's tentatively
called something deeply hidden based on
a quote from Albert Einstein but my
publishers give me rumblings that they
might not like that title so it's a
subject to change it's gonna be coming
out in September 2019 takes a long time
for a book to be produced and copy
edited and all that stuff and it frankly
it's not even done yet it should have
been done but the draft is very very
close to being done it's about quantum
mechanics does the world really need
another book about quantum mechanics
like just this year several new books
came out trade books about pop about
quantum mechanics I think there's a
couple of things that will separate this
book of course every author thinks that
even if they're writing about the topic
that has been written about many times
they're doing it better right so I'm
trying to explain quantum mechanics in
the best way I know how
and I have put some effort into doing
that over the years so I have my
techniques for doing that but the things
that otherwise separate the book are
number one it's supposed to be an
explanation of and a defense of the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics a lot of books on quantum
mechanics at the popular with the trade
level emphasize how mysterious it is
honestly they go overboard trying to say
how it's so mysterious we'll just never
understand and even though what I'm
doing in something deeply hidden is
defending many worlds more importantly
I'm defending the idea that there can be
an answer to this question of what is
the deep meaning of quantum mechanics I
certainly mention competition right
alternatives to many worlds you know and
I try to give them a fair hearing now
the balance tearing because I have my
favorite one but a fair one and what
really matters to me is that people get
over this idea that it's impossible to
understand quantum mechanics I really
think that you know there's more than
one way that the world could be quantum
mechanical it's not that there are zero
ways if there's more than one way and we
should figure out which one of them is
right and I think that many worlds is my
favorite until some good arguments or
data come along and change my mind which
is of course always possible the other
thing the second thing that I think is
is different is that I put many worlds
to work like rather than just saying
what the theory is and talking about
some of the issues I try to make the
case one of the reasons why I care about
this is because in my own research in
physics and trying to think about
quantum gravity and emergent space-time
and cosmology I think these are areas
where it really matters what you think
about the fundamental formulation of
quantum mechanics whether it's
many-worlds or something else so I
talked in the last section of the book I
talk a lot about those things quantum
gravity emergent space-time and there's
been enormous ly interesting fascinating
discoveries or discoveries might be too
strong a word because there are
speculations at the moment but ideas
let's say that in the last few years
relating entanglement to space-time
geometry and the emergence of a classic
like we live in with a with a curved
space-time in it so all the stuff is
very very cutting edge it's not nearly
as solid and unreliable as the stuff I
talked in the first three quarters of
the book but it you know it gives people
a flavor for how this is not just
sitting back and bullshitting about you
know big ideas it's actually does have
applications to important physics
research so that will be a big part of
the book so certainly you know I haven't
talked about those topics that much on
the podcast but coming in 2019
especially as we get toward September
2019 there's gonna be a lot of quantum
mechanics on the podcast let's just say
that solo and otherwise otherwise you
know beside writing the book and
starting the podcast the other big thing
that is taking up my time this year is
my actual day job of doing science
research to be perfectly honest this was
not a very productive year for science
research because precisely of the fact
that I started the podcast and finished
the book so I'm very much looking
forward in 2019 to going back to a much
more normal schedule there I got a
couple papers out this year I actually
got two
philosophy papers out one on
falsifiability and the multiverse and
the other one on the question that I had
in the solo podcast of is there
something why is there something rather
than nothing so those are both invited
contributions to big edited collections
which might appear in 2019 you know I
think the Rutledge companion to physics
or something like that but that's a lot
of fun to sort of dabble in things that
are kind of in my area but didn't
stretching my my expertise let's put it
that way and then in terms of real
physics papers I had two papers with a
Schmidt Singh who is a graduate student
here at Caltech we're we're starting
from the very basics of quantum
mechanics and seeing how we're trying to
lay the foundation for this program that
I kind of already mentioned about how
quantum entanglement can lead to
space-time and geometry so this is the
kind of thing where it's a big hard
program right and it could crash and
fail at any moment you in some sense
what we have is a new approach to
quantum
where I gloss it as saying rather than
quantizing gravity we're finding gravity
within quantum mechanics so the first
question is how do you find anything
within quantum mechanics you know like
if you just the the thing is that we're
so poisoned or influenced by the fact
that we human beings think classically
right we see things we can see baseballs
and we think that they have a position
and a velocity and quantum mechanics
comes along and says that they don't
really those are things you can observe
or they don't exist until you observe
them in some sense so what exists what
exists in quantum mechanics is this
thing called the wavefunction the
quantum state which is an abstract
vector in some giant vector space and so
how do you make the transition from what
quantum mechanics really is about to the
world we see I'm convinced that almost
everyone in the world cheats at that
question because they already know what
we see so they kind of put in the answer
by hand and so what Ash mean I've been
doing is working on the question of how
do you get from the quantum state all by
itself to say oh this is a quantum state
representing a cat or a molecule or the
universe right what are the
characteristics of the quantum state
that let you say things like that so
we've had a couple of papers out on that
we have this program that we have dubbed
mad dog Eveready anism
if any of you listen to the podcast with
Alex Rosenberg he has been called a mad
dog naturalist so I like that so much
that I borrowed it to enable label mad
dog ever-ready nism which means that not
only do you have just a wavefunction and
it's evolution equation the Schrodinger
equation you don't help yourself to a
preferred set of observables or anything
like that ordinarily in a quantum theory
you say this is a theory of a particle
with the position or something like that
then you can go and ask what the
position does over time but the position
is the thing you observe and observing
is something that gets done you know by
subsets of the universe it's not there
at the deepest level of the quantum
description all by itself so that really
shouldn't be the language in which you
formulate your most basic version of
quantum mechanics
so the mad dog Eveready and says we
start from
quantum mechanics in its own right in
its own terms and try to show how
everything else emerges from that again
it's a hard problem but we're making
progress and we have a bunch of papers
sort of in different levels of
completion some essentially finished I
just need to edit them and submit them
and a couple you know halfway through
and a couple just in cogitation but all
in the general area of this program of
starting with the very basics of quantum
mechanics and entanglement and using
tools from quantum information theory to
get how space-time emerges hopefully
we'll make progress on that like I said
it's a program it could crash from
burden anytime we all know that we're
taking some leaps here but I've been
working on this for a few years now with
some other grad students
Charles tau Aidan Chatwin Davies and
another collaborators and I think that
you know it's actually going pretty well
so we'll see how it goes I'm also trying
to get back a little bit into
statistical mechanics I wrote a paper a
few years ago with Stefan liking our
who's a postdoc and a couple of our
students at Caltech where we derive what
we called the Bayesian second law of
thermodynamics this may be this would be
a good topic for a solo podcast someday
but there's been a little mini
revolution in the last 15 or 20 years in
statistical mechanics where based on the
idea of fluctuation theorems you know we
all know entropy goes up but Boltzmann
back in the 1870s explained to us that
it's it's really the second law of
thermodynamics really says that entropy
is just really really likely to go up
and the reason it's really really likely
to go up is because there's a lot of
particles right 10 to the 23 particles
in a macroscopic system so what if you
have just like 10 or 20 particles
well then entropy would still tend to go
up but the probability is you know
closer to 90% rather than 99.99999% so
the fluctuations around the average
behavior become very important and this
is crucially important for the real
world for you know biological organisms
in our cells there's very tiny pieces
that usually BK behave in
thermodynamically censer sensible ways
but sometimes fluctuate downward so
there's this whole new
way of thinking about non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics that was launched
by Christopher yards in ski and Gavin
crooks and others that is really
blossomed and I'm very interested in it
but I haven't actually other than that
one paper on the Bayesian second law
dealt that deeply into it but I'm
getting back into it I think that
there's important connections there
between statistical mechanics and
causality cause-and-effect and you know
like I said life itself biophysics the
origin of life things like that so I'm
looking forward to getting more involved
with that I'm getting more and more
involved with the Santa Fe Institute in
New Mexico which is an institute devoted
to studying complexity and so you know
my Caltech colleagues don't really care
about all that mech stuff and complexity
stuff but the SFI people really do so
it's been very stimulating and fun to
talk with them and I look forward to
increasing that collaboration that's
been most of my stuff that's been no you
know major secret projects this year
2018 in in the past I've consulted on
movies a little bit and there is a movie
coming out called The Avengers end game
which I did consult on so I can't tell
you what it's about I cannot tell you
what we talked about but hopefully some
of the things I said as one of the
various science consultants it's not
just me they talk to a bunch of people
so there should be some really
interesting ideas in the New Avengers
movie I'm hoping you know science
consulting is a weird game because you
go in there you have several hours of
intense conversation with directors and
screenwriters and then you leave and
then that's it and then two years later
a movie comes out so you don't have much
control as a science consultant over how
your ideas were actually put into the
final script so I'm as curious as you
are to see what the movie is actually
gonna be and then to close up you know
the state of the world the state of the
world right now is a mess you probably
know as I'm recording this at the end of
December we're having a partial shutdown
of the United States government because
let's just say certain important actors
in the government individual one wants
to build a wall that would separate us
from Mexico
and you know we're not going to go into
the details of the immigration debate or
the political ramifications or the
strategies going on there but I do think
it's there's a symbolism here that is
hard to mistake of building a wall
around your country right of shutting
yourself off and it's a very inward
looking
selfish myopic way to be a citizen of
the world in my view and I hope that the
attitude conveyed in this podcast and in
other things that I do is the opposite
of that is outward going is cosmopolitan
is open to new experiences and varied
and diverse and curious and questioning
and talking to people who you agree with
and who you don't agree with you know
one of the things that I'm fascinated by
intellectually as well as practically
does the idea of disagreement you know
one of the many books that I want to
write down the down the road in the
future it would be a book on the nature
of disagreement and how it matters and
how you deal with it like in politics
and science we try to get rid of
disagreement right we have disagreement
it's there but we think that there's a
right answer and you're just gonna find
it and there are techniques for doing
that - there's rationality and evidence
and so forth and these are great in
politics or further than that in any
question about values or how you live in
the world there's this whole other
situation where you might not agree even
if you're both really smart and rational
right you might have fundamentally
different values that you start from
whether or not you think that you know
you could be sort of content and think
that rational people will always
uniquely end up with the same value
system or you could be more human and
you can admit the truth of it which is
that people can just disagree about
these things as a practical matter in a
world in a liberal democracy where you
want to have people govern themselves
the people doing that governing you're
going to disagree about some things so
it's great to try to remove that
disagreement through rational
argumentation and evidence but meanwhile
you have to learn to live with
disagreement you have to learn to get
along at at least a practical way with
people who
degree with and so I'm just fascinated
by you hopefully we'll have some
podcasts with good guests talking about
how to live in a world where we don't
agree with everybody what is the
political philosophy of that what's the
psychology of that what's the you know
status of how to get to better
disagreement when we start with from
very different values so I think this
that's a fun thing to talk about I hope
that my little podcast mindscape can do
it's incredibly small part in nudging
the world towards looking outward and
accepting and trying to make things
better
rather than huddling inward and hoping
the scary monsters will leave us alone
that's the holiday message here from
mindscape world headquarters thanks very
much for listening and have a good 2019
[Music]
you
[Music]